[Music]
[Music]
the quiet place was one of the most
unlikely hits of 2018
[Music]
made on a budget of just 17 million
dollars the horror film would go on to
gross more than 332 million dollars
worldwide Emily Blunt earned praise for
her performance and actor John Krasinski
had his first major breakthrough as a
director one thing that makes the movie
so unique its use of sound a quiet place
is set in a post-apocalyptic world
overrun with monsters with ultra
sensitive hearing make a single sound
and you're in big trouble
therefore the characters communicate in
sign language and make the lightest of
footsteps while the movie is a
groundbreaking lack of sound that
doesn't mean it's completely absent of
it brandon jones ethan van Duren and
erik Adol of e squared are responsible
for much of what you hear on screen
sound was actually written into the
script and so for us it was like a dream
come true like kids in a candy store
here's how some of the movie's most
notable sounds were made fully a method
in which objects are used to create
sounds made by humans or in this case
monsters was used a Foley stage is a
super quiet environment where we can put
picture up on the screen and then record
using our microphones in sync with the
picture some sounds like a shotgun
loading and water splashing were made
exactly as you'd expect
for other sounds they had to get
creative the most unusual sound might be
the echolocation sounds used to
illustrate how the monsters get around
without vision to make this sound they
settled on putting a stun gun up to a
patch of grapes
they've then manipulated the sound in
the next phase the editing process the
whole concept with these creatures is
there's kind of an electromagnetic
component so using something electrical
as a source for the vocals seem to kind
of make sense so here's our recording of
the stun gun we can take that sound and
slow it down
and we can hear the individual Electric
clicks
[Music]
not every sound effect requires fully
for the sound of a baby crying Brandon
Jones recorded the sound of his baby
nephew crying one of the biggest
challenges of this movie wasn't what you
heard with ease but the kind of sounds
we might normally tune out footsteps are
a classic Foley noise any sound
designers used to making usually it'll
be loud but for a quiet place the team
had to account for the fact that the
characters mostly walked around barefoot
where we would play fully footsteps
we're not - were really dictated by the
logic of the film on a lot of why shots
we didn't even shoot the Foley for those
feet if we can hear it from such a
distance
the creatures can too and then when you
cut into an extreme close-up and you see
a foot push through sand then we hear it
just chiaroscuro the scariest sound of
all though the lack of sound it's rare
that you get to work on a movie that has
this much like absolute silence and
parts where music and dialogues all
stripped away and it's just these faint
details one of the biggest things that
happen throughout the course of
post-production for this movie was
really scaling back and being more
minimalist in the creature sound design
because our first pass had him making
noise all over the place and we kept
scaling back and making it kind of a
less is more approach following in the
path of one of the great monster movies
before it jaws the less we see or in
this case the less we hear from the
monsters the more terrifying they are
and yet good luck getting that stun gun
sound out of your head now